just a few short months after his split
with grimes back in september it appears
that the billionaire tech mogul and
world's richest man elon musk is dating
again so who is this new girlfriend what
does she do what are her hobbies is elon
musk getting married spoiler alert it's
an actress like amber heard elon musk's
previous girlfriend make sure to watch
till the end to find out all about elon
musk's new love interest without further
ado let's begin
the photos
as reported by business insider on
february 17 2022 50 year old elon musk
was photographed disembarking his 70
million dollar private jet the flashy
19-seater g530er with a mystery woman
who was soon identified as a 24 year old
australian actress natasha bassett the
photo showed them driving off together
in a waiting tesla according to business
insider bassett was reportedly disguised
in a long black trench coat and
sunglasses the two were spotted after
landing in los angeles the photos were
initially published by hollywoodlife but
as expected they were all over social
media within minutes
it's a serious relationship an unknown
source said to be close to musk revealed
that the two have been dating for a
couple of months now and are in a
serious monogamous relationship the
source added that the two love birds are
very much into each other and are
spending a lot of time together he also
revealed that natasha joined elon on
back and forth work trips to austin well
that's a good sign right there the two
started dating a while after musk's
breakup with grimes but it was very
casual at first not long after that they
noticed that they had a real connection
which the source described as
unbelievable chemistry according to the
source natasha has fallen for elon's
brains and not his bank balance the two
were just friends and they became
romantic only after the billionaires
split with grimes now let's find out
more about the actress who is natasha
bassett
the australian actress will play elvis
presley's first love dixie lock in an
upcoming baz luhrmann elvis presley
biopic starring austin butler as elvis
and tom hanks as his manager the movie
is set to be released on june 24th
bassett is best known for her role as
britney spears and lifetime's 2017
biopic britney ever after she also had a
role in joel and ethan cohen's 2016
movie called hail caesar where she
starred alongside george clooney and
scarlett johansson the 24 year old
actress was born and raised in sydney
but when she was 19 she decided to move
to new york to attend drama school her
acting career started five years prior
to that when she was playing a lead role
in romeo and juliet with the australian
theater for young people in 2009 bassett
played the lead role in the mtv movie
dunguna which was also her debut on film
she also starred in a few series in
australia including rake cops lac and
wild boys besides acting natasha bassett
is also very passionate about baking in
an interview with vogue australia she
revealed that she baked every day as she
was waiting to find out whether she got
the role in hail caesar just to get her
mind off it let's hope elon likes
muffins and cupcakes her hobbies also
include hiking and she is also very
passionate about issues such as global
warming and animal rights wow isn't that
sweet elon musk's previous relationships
back in september 2021 elon musk broke
up with the 33 year old canadian singer
claire elise voucher better known as
grimes after three years of dating the
two have a two-year-old son named x-a-12
[Music]
also as a vanity fair profile of the
musician has recently discovered grimes
and elon musk secretly welcomed a new
baby girl why via surrogate in december
as for the reason for this breakup elon
musk explained that it mostly had to do
with the fact that his work at tesla and
spacex requires him to be primarily in
texas or traveling overseas while her
work is primarily in los angeles musk
also revealed in his recent interview
with page six that they plan to
co-parent their son we are
semi-separated but still love each other
see each other frequently and are on
great terms elon told the publication
and yet 33 year old grimes has since
released the single player of games
where she apparently threw shade at musk
the song is basically about being in
love with the greatest gamer who will
always love the game more yup sounds
like musk to me sail away to the cold
expanse of space even love couldn't keep
you in your place the lyric says in case
you have any doubt who this song is
about before grimes the tech mogul dated
actress amber heard after their split
musk talked about his love life in an
interview with rolling stone magazine
revealing that he prefers long-term
relationships he said that he can't be
happy if he's not in a long-term
relationship and that going to sleep
alone kills him elon musk has been
married a total of three times twice to
the english actress tallulah riley and
once to the author justine musk with
whom he shares five sons with that we
must end today's video what do you think
about elon musk's new relationship let
us know in the comments down below